The sauce, Kevin here,
and you are lying to yourself basically all day long.
You don't even know it.
And sometimes other people are conspiring to steer your mind where it
shouldn't go. You get patterns wrong, you get numbers wrong,
you get prices and values wrong. And it's totally not your fault.
Right wrong.
It's why 40,320 is actually greater than
40,320.
Huh?
Okay. I've got two very simple math problems here under these papers.
Eight and beat choose the one you want to solve.
Choose right now. Do you want to solve eight or do you want to solve B?
Go ahead. Okay. Now that you've chosen.
When I flipped the papers over to expose the problems,
you'll have exactly five seconds to solve the one you chose.
And if you don't have enough time to solve it,
you could just estimate the answer ready?
[Inaudible].
Time's up. All right. Let's be honest.
Virtually no one was able to multiply those numbers fast enough,
at least not accurately. But what about your estimates? We know that one times,
two times, three times, four times, five times, six times,
seven times eight and eight times, seven times, six times, five times,
four times, three times,
two times one are the exact same problem because of the community of property,
which is like a times B equals B times a.
It doesn't matter what order we multiply the terms start small,
get bigger, start big, get smaller. It makes no difference,
same result, but in a 1974 article called judgment under uncertainty,
heuristics and biases, Amos, Tversky,
and Daniel Conaman revealed that the group who tried to solve problem,
a multiplying with the small numbers first had a median estimate of
512 group B who started by multiplying larger
descending numbers.
Their median estimate was 2,250 over four
times higher than a, just because the order of the numbers was different.
That seems weird. No, that's normal.
We do this all the time and just don't know it. Oh,
and the actual answer to this problem is as you may have guessed
40,320,
so both groups were way off each other and way,
way off the truth.
The fact is whether you started with big numbers or small numbers,
you were anchored into a mode of thought that depended on your initial
information. Anchoring is a cognitive bias.
That basically sets the tone for how you think about something.
And it can be really tough to break out of it or consider other
relevant factors like video game prices.
I recently got into a teeny tiny Twitter argument about how $70
games now are actually cheaper than the prices of video games. 20 years ago,
paying 60 bucks in the year 2000 was actually $90 and
69 cents in real dollars,
but we'd been anchored into video game pricing,
even ignoring inflation.
We didn't talk about how games also now take longer to develop with way more
staff.
And the technology itself is a lot better with 4k graphics and smooth frame
rates, wireless controllers, full games. You can buy, download,
and play basically right away from your couch without having to beg your mom to
drive you to KB toys at the South side mall and Oneonta an hour round trip in a
sudden snowstorm to get a game, you know,
next to nothing about aside from having drooled over the same 10 screenshots in
game pro magazine for the last six spots.
But that game was Xeno gears and it was totally
worth it. And anchoring happens with stuff like movies,
how a movie opens and ends bookend anchoring has a
stronger influence on what you think of it. Have you ever heard someone say,
yeah, the beginning and end of that movie were terrible,
but the middle was really good.
No coin flipping muscle Pia tele Palm Maurine flipped a coin
seven times and the outcome was one of these three sequences,
heads, heads, heads, heads, tails, tails, tails, tails, heads, heads, tails,
heads, tails, tails, tails, tails, tails, tails, tails, tails, tails.
The question is which one is most likely to be the real outcome?
Let's say you had to bet on it. It costs you 10 bucks if you were wrong.
And if you were right you on 30 bucks, when a group was pulled,
the top choice was sequence two followed by one and then
three for all the wrong reasons.
The probabilities of all three sequences are exactly the same
because each coin flip is an independent event with 50 50 odds of
heads or tails seven tails in a row is just as likely to
occur as a mix of tails and heads in the second series.
But since we're anchored into thinking,
there's typically an alternating mix of heads and tails and a sequence of seven
coin tosses.
We wrongly believe it's actually more likely
[inaudible] dice.
I've painted four sides of this dye green and the other two sides, red,
same bedding terms as the coin flip game, lose 10 bucks if you're wrong.
When 30 bucks, if you're right, which outcome is more likely red, green, red,
red, red, green, red, green, red, red, red, green, red, red,
red, red, red, when people were polled,
choice preferences also went to one and three.
That is weird.
None of the three sequences are all that common because they're so red,
heavy and red is only two of the six sides of the dye.
But our cognitive bias tells us to choose the second
sequence because it's got a nice little mix. A nice,
I don't know why I did that.
It's got a nice little mix of red and green,
even though the first sequence is actually contained in the
second one. Look at this red, green, red, red, red, red, green, red, red,
red.
Why would it ever be easier to add an additional throw to make the
sequence more likely? It isn't. The more throws you make,
the less likely you are to hit that exact sequence.
Here's the math.
We're really just multiplying the odds of one over three for red and two over
three for green, but check out the relative probabilities,
just one swap from red to green in sequence. Number two,
doubles the probability of sequence number three and not requiring that
extra green throw in.
Number one makes it about 60% more likely to happen compared
to sequence. Number two, anchoring costs you money.
The next time you're shopping and you see something that's 1999. Yeah.
20 bucks sounds a lot more expensive,
even though it's just a penny difference,
but that 99 cents also anchors you into thinking about the
price in an interval of pennies.
So sales and holding dollars off seems more appealing. Look,
if a car sticker price is $18,000,
even you might counter with $15,000 even,
but a car at $17,800 is meant to anchor you into
countering in hundreds, not thousands.
I began this video with this multiplication example because it's the clearest
illustration of how anchoring bias can lead to groups with the same
information, just presented differently to reach totally different
conclusions. Both of which were dramatically wrong.
Anchoring is a good thing.
It's a first impression we have to start somewhere if we're ever going to
process any information in a meaningful or efficient
way, but it can definitely lead you down the wrong path and without
recognizing what it is. And isn't,
you just have no hope of overcoming its effects,
but by acknowledging, anchoring bias,
your armed with the ability to choose how much weight to give it,
you can stick with the good,
accurate anchors that lead you down the right roads.
And you can transcend those that otherwise would have caused you to
get it really wrong.
The truth is that depending on the question,
the real answer might still be just floating
around, waiting for someone,
someone like you to finally anchor it.
And it's always thanks for watching real quick.
This video is sponsored by the Ridge wallet.
Put this wallet in your front pocket, not your back.
Look at this honkin wallet I used to sit on all day, look at this once.
Even in the year receipt, old business card, what's this? Oh,
a nice picture of Michael, a nice picture of Jake bloom. Kevin,
get out of here. All I need is the Ridge wallet.
It holds up to 12 cards plus cash,
and there's over 30 colors and styles like bird titanium and carbon fiber.
They have over 30,005 star reviews and it comes with a lifetime warranty.
So you buy one wallet and just use it forever and ever,
and ever you'll get 45 days to try it out. And if it's not for you,
just return it for a full refund. How about that?
Get 10% off today with free worldwide shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com/vsauce two that's
rindge.com/vsauce to use code Vsauce to on sauce to link down to the description
below. Okay.
[Inaudible].